peut-être avant d'être recruté à lagence
les conditions dans laquelle ont été
recrutés et ce quelles étaient vos
missions à l'agent ce parce que en
lisant le rapport sur le médiator
vous êtes effectivement beaucoup cité
peut-être un peu moins que d'autres mais
beaucoup cité on ne saisit pas toujours
quelles sont vos fonctions notamment
qu'elles ont sans doute dû évoluer par
rapport à ce qu'elle était au début
lorsque il s'agissait de l' agence du
médicament dont je vous laisse la parole
dans un premier temps pour que vous nous
que vous répondiez à cette question
concernant votre votre curriculum vitae
en quelque sorte vous avez la parole
nous devons dire que nos travaux sont
ouverts notamment à la presse et je
voulais vous informer madame je crois
que vous étiez au courant non parce que
vous avez vous auriez la possibilité de
refuser justement la présence de la
presse
soyons transparents d'accord oui je vous
en prie vous avez la parole bien
donc avant de rejoindre l' agence du
médicament
lors de sa création j'ai exercé toute ma
carrière dans le service public à
l'hôpital fernand widal d'abord comme
médecin attaché puis assistante des
hôpitaux et six ans des universités
puisque j'ai été diplômé en santé
publique
et puis ensuite nommé praticien
hospitalier en 1986 en pharmacologie
clinique
à ce titre j'ai d'abord exercé dans le
service du professeur fournier au centre
antipoison de paris j'ai fait partie des
premiers toxicologue et pharmacologue
qui ont créé le système de
pharmacovigilance avec les premiers
centres de pharmacovigilance dans les
années 74 75 qui ont été créés
évidemment
à la demande des chefs de service de
l'époque puisqu'il a fallu attendre le
décret de 1984 pour que la
pharmacovigilance soit officiellement
créé donc tout au long de ces années là
jusqu en 1993 j'ai évidemment pratique
et la toxicologie clinique de la
pharmacologie la pharmacovigilance
puisque j'ai animé et géré le centre de
pharmacovigilance de l'hôpital fernand
widal à paris j'ai j'avais bien sûr une
activité aussi de consultation et au
début des années 90 c'est vrai que j'ai
envisagé de modifier mon parcours je ne
savais pas très bien comment et il se
trouve que en 1993 lors de la création
de l' agence du médicament
le professeur jean-michel alexandre qui
devait prendre les fonctions de
directeur de l'évaluation du médicament
à chercher parmi les pharmacologues et
les pharmaco vigilant à un candidat qui
serait prêt à rejoindre l' agence du
médicament
donc après quelques réflexions j'ai
accepté j'ai accepté dans un premier
temps d'ailleurs à titre temporaire ne
sachant pas très bien si j'étais
évidemment pour rejoindre
l'administration ou pour continuer ma
carrière de praticiens hospitaliers
donc après quelques mois en sifflet
puisqu'il fallait quand même que je
puisse continuer à gérer le centre de
pharmacovigilance de paris fermant vidal
j'ai finalement rejoint complètement à
temps plein début des années
quatre-vingt quatorze début des années
quatre-vingt quatorze donc le ça n'a pas
été un choix va c'était un choix guidé
par effectivement
là les échanges que j'ai pu avait à voir
avec le professeur jean michel alexandre
mais aussi guidé par cette volonté de
voilà de modifier me modifié ma carrière
et de quitter l'hôpital je dois dire que
ça a été
c'était pas facile au tout départ parce
que je ne connaissais pas bien
l'administration et que je travaillais
sur le terrain et que pendant très
longtemps jusqu'à il ya deux ans j'ai
gardé une activité de consultation à
l'hôpital parce que je pensais que
c'était très important de garder
voilà le contact avec la clinique et en
ayant une demi journée de consultations
par semaine et puis tous les quinze
jours et puis à 2 ans à la suite
d'ailleurs d'un accident j'ai été obligé
d'arrêter ce d'autant que je vais quand
même aussi à côté de mes responsabilités
à lagence des responsabilités
européennes qu'ils et que donc à un
moment où il faut à partir de 80 14
arrêts exercer quelle fonction exacte
alors j'ai d'aval ajouté j'ai d'abord
été j'ai d'abord été effectivement
rejoint l' agence pour exercer les
fonctions de chef d'unité de la
pharmacovigilance
la mission étant de créer organiser la
pharmacovigilance à l' agence du
médicament en sachant que cette agence
dans l'année qui suivait devait intégrer
l'europe du médicament avec la création
de l'agencé européenne du médicament
le 1er janvier 1995 ce qui veut dire
qu'à partir du 1er janvier 95 j'étais
aussi représentant français au groupe de
pharmacovigilance européen
95 le début on n'a pas depuis 2006 95
nom d'où la naissance ou l'utilité de
ces auditions et parce que ça correspond
pas tout à fait aux indications nous
avions mais c'est vous qui dakar qui
avait raison forcément
donc inutile de vous demander si vous
avez ou avaient eu des liens d'intérêts
avec les laboratoires
si c'est le cas c'est il ya très
longtemps
ja je n'ai jamais eu bien jamais mal
très bien parfait mais coûté 115 tarder
je vais passer la parole à madame la
rapporteur qui va vous poser un certain
nombre de questions on va commencer donc
si vous le voulez bien sûr deux parties
pour permettre on va procéder à cet
interrogateur à cet interrogatoire en
deux parties une première qui concernera
donc la sphère du médiateur proprement
dit est une deuxième si on a le temps
mais compte tenu de ce départ que nous
prônons je doute que nous ayons le temps
de procéder la deuxième partie puisqu'il
faut aussi que les commissaires puissent
vous poser les questions qu'ils
souhaitent vous posez donc je vous
conseille je vous suggère madame à
porter de faire une première tranche de
questions concernent affaire du médiator
on passe ensuite la parole aux
commissaires et après si nous avons tant
nous reprenons nous continuons sur les
questions de la partie b qui porte sur
l'évaluation un contrôle du médicament
vous avez la parole
notre mission madame comporte non
seulement le médiator mais tout le
système d'évaluation et de contrôle du
médicament
donc vous êtes chef de service de la
surveillance du risque du bon usage et
de l'information sur les médicaments à
l'afssaps
quand et comment avez vous été informé
pour la première fois des effets nocifs
du médiator qui a été mis sur le marché
à partir peu
de 76 la presse de ce jour rappelle
qu'en belgique par exemple son
enregistrement a été refusé dès 1977
quelles mesures avez-vous alors engagé
de deuxième deuxième question qu'on
pourrait en recomposition par questions
qu'elles soient parfaites 2e de deux
questions et de huy connaissez-vous les
suites qui ont été données aux premières
analyses relatifs aux dangers des
factures amine notamment dans les
conclusions de l'étude de l'î -p -é phs
de 1995 et comment ont été traités les
informations provenant des 1998 des
unités de pharmacovigilance de l'agencé
et j'ajouterais si vous le peuvent sur
un jour le père mais puisque je suis
président je m'excuse mais quand
avez-vous su que le médiator s'appelait
benfluorex est est ce que vous avez
établi le lien qui pouvait y avoir avec
la avec le la liste de dci de d2
dénomination commune internationale qui
avait été établie à plumes 50 par l' oms
avec chaque famille thérapeutique à ce
qu'on appelle un segment clé est que
tout ce qui est au rex est forcément un
anorexigène
alors il est important de savoir à quel
moment vous avez fait cette liaison est
est ce que vous l'avez fait un jour bon
j'ai entendu un grand professeur qui m'a
dit je me suis aperçu qu'en 2009 que le
benfluorex existait alors effectivement
tout est possible mais est ce que oui
non mes cheveux je sais de quoi je sais
le professeur abenhaim dans une
interview du figaro - qui le disait
madame
casto vous avez la parole lors les trois
questions en fait sont sont séparés mais
en même temps évidemment il y a un lien
entre les trois alors je voudrais
commencer par la seconde comme ça on
comprendra pourquoi je reviens à la
première parce que lorsque j'ai rejoint
l' agence nous étions déjà en dans
l'évaluation dans cette démarche de
réévaluation des risques des
anorexigènes les amphétaminique et les
fins furent à munich et que à l'époque
lorsque je suis arrivé c'était déjà un
dossier qui est que nous avions en
charge le système de pharmacovigilance
et bien sûr la dp h&m et que cette
fameuse année 94 a été une année
charnière pour nous puisque nous étions
dans la tente des premiers résultats des
résultats préliminaires intermédiaires
de cette fameuse étude conduite par
lucien benhaim dit ip phs 1 qui avait
été au départ une demande du laboratoire
servier
mais que nous avions totalement validé
et ensuite en grande partie pris à notre
charge
bien sûr et il avait été dit que les
pays qui les agences des pays qui
participaient à certes étude devait être
de manière confidentielle
bien sûr informés des résultats donc
pour ce qui est des amphétaminiques et
des fins furent à munich c'est un
dossier dont que j'ai pris en charge dès
mon arrivée en janvier 94 et que j'ai
suivie jusqu'au bout puisque vous devez
savoir que l' affaire a été portée à
l'europe et que la france a été nommé
rapporteur pour ce dossier
donc j'ai participé à l' expertise
européenne des des anorexigènes aussi
bien les amphétaminique que les femmes
furent à munich
la première rencontre avec le benfluorex
médiator pour moi est assez tardive elle
date de du milieu des années
quatre-vingt quinze ans et je vais
expliquer pourquoi
simplement je voudrais porter à votre
attention un point c'est que lorsque
les résultats de l'étude ip phs nous ont
amenés à communiquer nos inquiétudes à
l' agence européenne à la suite de la
demande d'arbitrage par l'allemagne
le dossier évidemment a enfin la
démarche de réévaluation a commencé à
l'europe avec un tour de table des pays
pour connaître quels étaient les
anorexigènes qui était sur les marchés
européens
et je voudrais dire donc que la première
occasion qui était peut-être
effectivement de faire sortir le
benfluorex que ce soit la france ou
d'autres pays qu'il avait sur le marché
a été une occasion qui n'a pas été
suivie pour la mesure où seuls les
produits qu'ils avaient une autorisation
de mise sur le marché dans l'indication
aide à la perte de poids 1 ou
anorexigène ont été pris en compte dans
l'évaluation européenne
tout ça pour dire que à la fin ou en 95
vous n'avez rien fait pour essayer de
démontrer que la noc cole influent au
rex vous me devez vous poser la question
à quel moment j'ai découvert le
benfluorex gelé découvert après oui
puisque je me souviens très bien qu'une
des questions mais c'est tout à fait
informelle était dans l' dans l'est
d'après ce que j'ai entendu dans l'étude
ip phs il y avait évidemment tous les
medics le paquet des anorexigènes qui
était évalué comme facteur de risque est
que le benfluorex avait été à l'époque
ranger rentrer ranger dans la catégorie
des zips aux lipides ayant pourquoi l'om
est il contraire l'om sg classe dans les
anorexigènes je je je réponds que j'ai
découvert le benfluorex avec ses effets
anorexigènes
quand tu le mets en bien plus tard bien
plus tard
en ce qui me concerne je vais beaucoup
plus tard que l'année écoutez je pense
que quand je me suis posé la question en
96 de la raison pour laquelle il était
sur la liste 3 de la loi talon qui
lisent 3,96 pourtant 680
qu'est-ce que oui j'avais sollicité j'ai
été sept fois talon alors d'une année
monsieur veuillez m'excuser c'est
peut-être 415 lorsque nous avons il faut
être précis
veuillez m'excuser souvent 95 95
j'essaye de bien mémoriser la cdvr
nous voyons figure voilà donc voilà donc
ces 95 il ya eu un arrêté d'interdiction
d'un certain nombre de produits dans les
préparations magistrales en deux temps
le premier temps avec les années c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que le premier
temps était avant le début de
l'évaluation européenne au moment où par
mesure de précaution et par nous nous
décidons que les anorexigènes ayant une
autorisation de mise sur le marché en
france devait être effectivement
interdit dans les préparations
magistrales et puis une commission de
pharmacovigilance au début de l'été 95
revoit l'ensemble du dossier est dit que
par mesure de précaution il faut non
seulement interdire les autres
anorexigène qui était sur les marchés
européens et que nous n'avions pas nous
en france
plus la liste qui était sur la liste 3
de la loi talent est là dans lequel il y
avait le benfluorex et c'est à ce moment
là que j'ai découvert le benfluorex et
je me suis posé la question mais c'est
personnel
ah ça ne nous engage que moi de la
raison pour laquelle il y était j'avais
bien repéré la parenté
structural jeu j'avais beau regarder les
indications du produit je m'étais posé
la question de la raison pour laquelle
ce produit était sur la liste sans
peut-être aller jusqu'au bout pour me
dis quand même il s'agit d'une erreur
non non c'est non non non non parce que
non non parce que je me suis dit que je
m'étais dit au moins se produit de toute
façon doit agir sur la perte de poids ne
serait ce que par ses effets
périphériques métabolique puisque de
toute façon c'était c'était utilisé dans
enfin c'était indiqué dans des troubles
métaboliques donc j'imaginais bien que
de toute façon il y avait au moins au
minimum un effet périphériques et que le
fait de le raisonnement que nous avons
tenu à l'époque pour effectivement
l'interdire dans les préparations
magistrales c'était un raisonnement par
précaution en se disant oh moi nous en
pharmacovigilance on a beaucoup de mal à
surveiller les produits qui sont
prescrits en préparation magistrale
donc prenons effectivement cette cette
précaution d'interdire toute cette liste
de produits et on surveillera d'autant
mieux les spécialités qui resteront sur
le marché nous n'avions pas cette à
l'époque si vous voulez c'est n'avions
pas fait pris cette décision par comment
dire sur des arguments pharmacologique
de 2 qui nous faisait penser qui nous
faisait qu'ils pouvaient nous faire dire
que le benfluorex était de la même
famille que les autres anorexigène
c'était par précaution
10 pour les préparations magistrales
pourquoi cette interdiction n'a pas
l'air n'at-elle pas été étendu pour les
préparations pharmaceutiques
d'autant plus que l'un des arguments qui
a été utilisée pour étendre cette
interdiction aux boeufs lurex c'est pour
éviter qu'il y ait des déplacements de
deux prescrit libre alors je comprends
bien qu'on interdise le d'un futur ex en
préparation et qu'on ne dise pas mais si
on l'interdît en préparation il va y
avoir un déport sur le benfluorex
mais c'est vrai qu'il s'appelait
médiator peut-être que vous n'avez pas
fait le lien entre benfluorex médiator
c'est possible puisque ne pas utiliser
la dec
la dénomination commune internationale
conduit à ce genre d'erreurs et je
voudrais aussi vous demander pourquoi
cette prise de conscience que vous avez
eue
vous l'avez garder pour vous vous n'avez
pas parlé avec les gens nous ont dit non
mais n'aurait pas parlé à monsieur
alexandre par exemple j'ai pas non déjà
nous avons eu tort de garder 500 euros
je ne répondais compte si vous n'aviez
pas garder ça pour vous ce que vous nous
auriez fait gagner je ne réponds pas
monsieur je ne connais pas je peux pas
répondre parce que ma mémoire ne me
risque de faillir et de jeu je ne peux
pas dire que je n'en avais pas parlé je
pense qu'à l'époque nous étions quand
même c'était quand même d'abord le
directeur de l'évaluation et il me
semble que c'était difficile en tant que
chef d'unité de pharmacovigilance de ne
pas partager toutes les toutes les
questionnements que nous pouvions voir
et c'est bien pour ça que j'ai dit au
début que je pensais que c'est un
raisonnement très personnel que je que
j'avais fait est que le montre le
raisonnement que nous avions parce que
je vous rappelle qu'à l'époque la
pharmacovigilance était encore une
pharmacovigilance peut-être deux comme
je le dis quelquefois je pousse un peu
mais a posteriori c'est à dire que
c'était une pharmacovigilance 2 1 pour
nous prenions des décisions fondées un
peu sur des certitudes c'est à dire que
la la les choses ont changé depuis ont
évolué mais c'est vrai que c'était un
produit je dois dire que moi
pharmacologue je ne connaissais pas je
ne prescrivent ai pas je n'avais jamais
prescrit du médiator
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui
n'était pas du tout dans ma dent may
pharmacopée
que je n'avais absolument pas et qu'ils
n'avaient pas été mis à l'ordre du jour
de quelconque réunion lorsque nous
avions commencé à faire la réévaluation
de l'ensemble des anorexigènes et de
quelconque réunion y compris à l'europe
à aucun moment parce qu'on peut nous se
reprocher la france de ne pas l'avoir
fait mais ni l'espagne ni l'italie ni lé
portugal ces pays qu'ils avaient sur le
marché et qui d'ailleurs en vue la
commercialisation du produit
arrêté bien avant nous ne se sont posé
la question et le raisonnement que nous
tenions à l'époque c'est que et je lutte
jeu pourrait le tenir pour encore pour
certains produits on a une grande
difficulté à surveiller correctement les
préparations magistrales qui ne sont
enregistrées par le feu le pharmacien
mais que nous ne connaissons pas à l'
agence et c'est un peu le raisonnement
que j'ai tenus en disant préparations
magistrales par principe de précaution
il faut arrêter tout de suite parce
qu'il peut y avoir du détournement en
revanche un médicament qui est une
spécialité qui normalement et est
surveillé par le système de
pharmacovigilance
s'il y a des notifications alors qu'il
n'y en avait pas à l'époque elle devrait
remonter et nous aurons nous aurons les
signaux dallaire tous les premiers
signaux qui nous permettra effectivement
de pouvoir mieux appréhender profil de
risque oui je vais vous n'avez pas
répondu à la question de vrais amateurs
de l'arabe menteur
les raisons pour lesquelles vous n'avez
pas retiré du marché le pain fluent ex
alors que vous leur tirez des
préparations magistrales qui lui n'a qu
il ya une incohérence qui n'est pas que
je ne prends pas aussi que vous aviez
sûrement connaissance de l'étude
confidentielle du cat et moi dont on
vient
de par les ip ps qui avait été demandée
en 1992 par l' agence du médicament et
on peut s'en étonner d'autant qu' on ne
comprend pas pourquoi aucun lien n'a été
établi avec le retrait de l'isoméride en
1997 aussi alors la parole en septembre
1997 à la demande des laboratoires
servier l'isoméride et pondérale sont
retirés de tous les marchés et arrive
alors une suspension d'autorisation de
mise sur le marché évidemment suspension
faites par les différentes agences
nous avions nous avions évidemment
connaissance de ces cas de
valvulopathies qu'on s'explique est très
mal ces valvulopathies qu'on avait vu
qu'aux états unis et uniquement aux
états unis nous avions des nous avions
essayé de comprendre pourquoi
oui bien sûr ne vous leurrez pas trouvé
non et probablement que la raison est
que les les conditions d'utilisation aux
états unis était différente des
conditions européennes à savoir qu'aux
états unis le produit était uni et est
utilisé par des vrais obèses puisque le
visiter et tu es vraiment un problème de
santé publique majeur et c'est bien pour
ça que les états unis ont mis le produit
sur le marché en 96 alors que nous nous
étions sur le point de le retirer en
europe et est souvent le plus souvent en
association comme vous le savez un autre
anorexigènes amphétaminiques la fin
termine alors qu'en france
l'isoméride comme dans beaucoup de pays
européens étaient plutôt utilisé par des
des patients qui étaient qui avait un
surpoids très modeste voire inexistant
et avec des durée moyenne de traitement
beaucoup plus courte et c'est encore ce
qu'on dit actuellement et en 97 la
première chose que nous avons faite
septembre 90 septembre 97
c'est d'essayer d'abord de voir si
effectivement cette problématique
exister en france
et puis très vite en europe parce que je
vous rappelle que la commission de
bruxelles a demandé à une réévaluation
même après la la le retrait d'isoméride
et pondérale a demandé une ré une
réévaluation du risque du bénéfice rice
et surtout du profil de risque des fins
furent à munich et des amphétaminiques à
l'europe et que nous avons été nommé
rapporteur et j'ai fait le rapport
d'évaluation avec mon équipe sur
pondérale isoméride et d'autre part sur
en fait prabonne les autres
amphétaminiques est entrée par d'autres
états membres et de nouveau avec toute
la toutes les données disponibles au
niveau européen on s'est aperçu que nous
n'avions pas ce problème de de
vallesvilles opt de valvulopathie en
europe sauf en belgique avec des
situations très particulières où il y
avait des co prescription de plusieurs
anorexigène et on retrouvait facilement
l'anf et rationnelle en belgique joue
signale qu'en france aussi est une déco
prescription et on a relevé
je vous rappelle que le rapport du crpv
de besançon qui les montrent qu'il ya 11
insuffisance hypertension pulmonaire
terrienne pulmonaire ceci résulte de
prescription en association de
l'isoméride et du boeuf lurex on est
bien d'accord
formés pour la première fois les effets
nocifs du médiator et comment ont été
traités les informations au sein des
unités de pharmacovigilance de l'agencé
hina on pourrait dire qu'il ya eu une
première période entre 95 et 97 fin 97
où le produit est sous surveillance par
de manière habituelle par un crpv qu'on
a nommé un bon pour centraliser
l'ensemble des données qui est le crpv
de besançon etc fin 97 début 98 qu'on se
dit suite à la sphère des fins furent à
munich et désinfecter des anorexigènes
avec une suspension pour et
hypertension artérielle pulmonaire et
valvulopathie il faut faire absolument
le point rapidement sur l'ensemble des
données de notifications spontanées
regarder le profil pharmacocinétique et
bien évidemment l'activité du produit
parce que à partir du moment où il n'y
avait plus d'un orexigen celle sur le
marché il y avait quand même ce risque
très fort non seulement de d'utilisation
et non de le diriger le jeu je me suis
mal exprimé des anorexigènes ayant une
autre une up ayant une autorisation de
mise sur le marché comme anorexigène
oui ah oui c'est subtil il faut oui oui
oui c'est effectivement tout le problème
est là précisément vous ai fait le point
et donc sur l'ensemble de ces données en
97 98
comment ce ces informations sont
traitées au sein des unités de
pharmacovigilance unités d'une dignité
de pharmaco vigilant donc l'unité de
pharmacovigilance demande à ce que le
début 98 je pense que c'est
je voudrais pas dire des alami 98 à ce
que le centre de pharmacovigilance de
besançon présente l'ensemble des données
disponibles sur le produit et ça fait
l'objet d'un comité technique à la fin
duquel nous disons en raison de la
parenté chimique delà du métabolisme 80
milles 4 non je parle 1098 mais il n'y a
pas eu de résultats officieux en 95 ans
il n'y avait absolument aucune données
de pharmacovigilance sur le produit et
c'est seulement à cause de la parenté
chimique et le fait que l'on pouvait
subodorer qui puisse y avoir des
déviations d'utilisation nous avions mis
en place une enquête de
pharmacovigilance qui était confiée à
besançon plus est cette enquête a été
renforcée et durcit à l'ami 98 oui mais
en 95 où il est déjà les premiers
éléments de cette enquête de besançon
les premiers éléments étaient et les
premiers éléments de l'enquète de 95
était très ténue en dehors de la parenté
chimique et du risque de déviation voilà
c'est tout ce que nous avions 17 98 donc
c'est donc neuf ans après en juillet
2007 que la commission d'autorisation de
mise sur le marché
supprime la première indication du
médiator relatives aux troubles du
métabolisme des lipides
pourquoi l'indication du traitement dans
le diabète avec surcharge pondérale at
elle était maintenue et à quels échanges
d'informations et d'expertisés avez-vous
procédé sur ce point avec les autres
agences sanitaires françaises je
voudrais juste faire un petit point wiki
est important j'ai quitté l'unité de
pharmacovigilance pour prendre en charge
la coordination des vigilances et aider
à monter à développer d'autres vigilance
en juillet 99
donc pendant toute une partie de mon
existence peu de mon exercice
professionnel à l'âge ans je suis passé
en deuxième position tout en étant quand
même évidemment toujours très proches
mais est en revanche comme vous avez dû
le voir j'ai été vice-président puis
président du groupe de pharmacovigilance
européens jusqu'à décembre 95
donc en fait à un moment donné c'est à
dire 'ok fin 98 il y a eu deux démarches
en même temps la démarche française qui
était l'enquète de pharmacovigilance sur
évidemment le produit et à partir de
septembre 98 suite à une une lettre du
professeur caratini mettant en exergue à
ce
cette proximité d'activité septembre 98
le professeur caratini écrit en disant
qu'il est qu'il pense qu'il faudrait que
ce produit soit intégrée dans la
réévaluation que nous étions en train de
faire sur les risques de valvulopathie
avec l'ensemble des anorexigènes à la
demande de la commission
c'est que le benfluorex était un
anorexigène
il le disait il le disait absolument et
vous que pensiez-vous à ce moment là
alors est ce que vous étiez d'accord
avec lui ou bien est ce que vous pensez
encore que c'était plutôt un
antidiabétique voyez-vous plutôt qu'un
anorexigène
en dépit de toutes les classifications
qui existent notamment celle de l' oms
je pense que je ne pouvais qu'admet
trente ans que pharmacologue et vul au
vu du métabolisme 1 puisqu'il se
métaboliser en norfenfluramine que
forcément par le biais de la
norfenfluramine qu'ont ces actifs
là le benfluorex partager les mêmes les
l'aller les mêmes propriétés veuillez
m'excuser oui que les fera minutes la
même nocivité disons le alors là même de
six mutés non je me posais des quais je
me posais des questions
je me posais des questions parce qu'à
l'époque la norfenfluramine
on disait qu'elle était impliqué dans la
survenue d hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire
on disait ça il s'est trouvé que des
travaux plus précis ont montré que
c'était peut-être pas la norfenfluramine
qui était seul qui jouait seul dans la
survenue d d hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire
on se posait la question du rôle de la
norfenfluramine dans la survenue des
valvulopathies rôle qui a été confirmée
avec les travaux de 2010 donc si vous
voulez y avait une grande à comment dire
un grand cortège d'arguments pour dire
qu'effectivement c'était
lalala le médiator devait se comporter
comme les femmes furent ami nick pas une
preuve
complètement enfin définitive et des
questions qu'on se posait sur le
mécanisme mais il n'empêche quand même
que 98 le fin 98 alors que l' enquête de
pharmacovigilance française continue le
la le professeur caratini et crie à l'
agence européenne l'agencé européenne
après une première évaluation bon de
cette lettre 1une comprise en
considération de cette lettre ne
considère pas immédiatement qui a
nécessité effectivement de de le prendre
en compte dans leurs évaluations qui
étaient en cours et demande alors au
groupe de pharmacovigilance dont j'étais
le vice président à l'époque avant de
venir le prêt avant d'être le président
un peu plus tardivement
deux de ceux de s'emparer de ce dossier
et c'est alors qu'au niveau du groupe de
pharmacovigilance il a été décidé de
faire une évaluation à deux pays
italie france oui alors bon les imams le
rapporteur - qui perd décidément le
rapporteur et parce que j'ai peut-être
des questions à poser encore simplement
savoir quand avec vous été informé des
décisions qui ont été prises dans
d'autres pays européens notamment
l'espagne et l'italie sur le retrait du
médiator et quelles ont été les
conséquences pour l' agence alors c'est
l'information de l'espagne je peux le
dire en tant qu' à l'époque président du
groupe de pharmacovigilance date de 2003
l'italie je n'ai pas le souvenir que
l'italie ait informé l'agencé européenne
puisque je rappelle qu'à cette époque là
j'étais tout à fait dans une autre mais
usage
j'étais dans un autre enfin j'avais
quitté complètement les du risque de
mésusage 5 indique du risque et du
mésusage des médicaments c'était ça non
pendant mon rôle mon rôle était de
m'occuper nom de la coordination des
vigilances c'est-à-dire de 2,2 de mettre
en place deux d'asseoir l'hémovigilance
donc produits sanguins labiles de créer
la biovigilance organes tissus cellules
de participer à la fin à l'organisation
de de la cosmétovigilance et de faire
que toutes les vigilances sécurité
sanitaire quelles qu'elles soient y
compris alimentaires y compris
environnement puisse effectivement
travailler ensemble dans la mesure où
envoyer bien déjà qu' il y avait des
risques transversaux qu'il fallait
prendre en compte
donc c'est une époque où j'étais à la
fois président du groupe de formats de
pharma que jean roch mais en demandant
une certaine neutralité et objectivité
vis-à-vis des dossiers dans la mesure où
j'étais là bas comme président et pas
comme représentant français et à côté de
ça un autre un autre une autre mission
jusqu'à l'été 2005 où le directeur
général de l'afssaps jean marimbert m'a
demandé de revenir pour renforcer le
système de gestion de risque et de
mettre en place notamment l'activité
plan de gestion de risque et études
pharmaco épidémiologiques vous beaucoup
mais ça ne veut pas dire que je n'étais
pas quand même je suis je ne suivais pas
le dos hier je ne veux surtout pas me
fait que le suivant je j'ai gelé suivi
mais j'étais je vois là vous pensez que
vous avez utilisé tous les moyens dont
vous aviez en particulier au regard de
l'article 12 pour imposer si vous voulez
à vos partenaires
peut-être une vision plus plus plus
rigoureuse 1,2 du benfluorex
est ce qu'il y avait à l'époque tous les
éléments qui vous permettait de demander
le retrait du benfluorex du marché alors
j'ai pas l'impression qu'à cette époque
là la france et fait entendre ce nouveau
au niveau européen au niveau européen et
c'est une constatation que je fais tous
les jours puisque je suis toujours à
l'europe
c'est extrêmement extrêmement difficile
et d'ailleurs c'est toute la
complication la complexité de ce dossier
c'est extrêmement difficile de se faire
entendre
lorsque vous êtes minoritaires avec un
produit c'est à dire que autant l'europe
fonctionne assez bien quand ce sont des
produits en procédure européenne où là
c'est un pour tous tous pour un et de
toute façon les décisions sont
contraignantes autant ce à deux c'est
plus compliqué j'espère que la révision
communautaire qui a été publié en
décembre à changer les choses avec les
procédures nationales pour des produits
ou qui ne sont pas sur tous les marchés
européens et c'était loin d'être le cas
pour benfluorex ce qui veut dire que une
grande majorité des pays ne s'intéresse
absolument pas la problématique et vous
voyez bien on l'a vécu récemment avec le
ketum allik qu'on a voulu re suspendus
du marché et l'europe a dit a dit non
non on n'est pas du tout d'accord
mais justement puisque c'était une
procédure qui n'étaient pas soumises à
autorisation européenne et sachant au
niveau européen que l'espagne dès 2003
avait décidé de retirer ce médicament
pourquoi finalement la france c'est la
question que se posent citoyenne base
pourquoi la france n'étant pas soumis à
cette procédure open n'at-elle pas pris
la même décision pour faire cesser le
jeu je me permets de dire excellent je
me permets de dire que lorsque l'espagne
nous a informés elle nous est pas dit
que c'est elle qui avait retiré du
marché pour voir gg non je je dis les
choses heures ma liste
bah écoutez moi en tout cas
bon encore une fois je connaissais le
cas le cas de valvulopathies espagnols
qui avaient été publiés au début des
années de l'année 2003 et s'est tassé de
manière contemporaine effectivement que
le laboratoire a décidé de cesser la
commercialisation mais il n'y a pas eu
en tout cas de la part de l'espagne dans
la formation qu'elle nous a fourni au
niveau européen j'entends un là là là ça
a été simplement un message qui était de
dire le benfluorex n'est plus
commercialisé sur dents sur le marché
espagnol vous pensez qu'il ya pas de
lien avec cette valvulopathies il est
évident si vous voulez tout dépend quand
on regarde le dossier dans sa globalité
maintenant que je me pose la question
bien évidemment mais à cette époque
j'étais encore une fois j'étais donc il
aurait fortement dans le dossier il
aurait fallu que servier retire son
médicament le flux rex en france pour
que je passais en soit débarrassé
je pense quand même eu peur c'est ça je
pense me permettre de dire une chose
c'est que le la fin la pharmacovigilance
repose sur évidemment l'ensemble des
informations qui non seulement nous
arrive des professionnels de santé
quelques sources que ce soit mais aussi
du laboratoire donc je me pose des
questions sur je n'ai pas eu de je n'ai
pas vu de courrier ou d'information
arrivé du laboratoire en 2003 pour nous
annoncer cette décision de d'arrêter la
commercialisation du produit non
seulement en espagne puis en italie bien
écoutez nous allons revenir mais pour le
moment nous allons passer enfin la
parole à nos collègues commissaires qui
sont venus nombreux c'est dire que cette
question intéresse
alors madame goulet me demande la parole
depuis pratiquement le début de la
séance 1 c'était lui donne la priorité
c'était pour menotter
au président ce n'était pas pour la
réclamer c'était juste pour m'inscrire
merci beaucoup je faisais moi
non c'était très intéressant écoutez je
suis pas médecin je suis pas pharmaciens
madame je suis un consommateur de base
et qui plus est conservateur de coupe
faim donc ce sujet m'intéresse moi j'ai
deux questions à vous poser
vous avez dit on a reçu l'aide du
laboratoire servier pour le pondéral
c'est ça vous avez été informé par le
laboratoire pour retirer ou l'isoméride
lorsque je terminais ma question
non ce courrier que vous avez reçue du
laboratoire quel est son circuit
d'examen et quelle est la publicité qui
est donnée à ce courrier qui vous arrive
du laboratoire qui attire l'attention
sur les risques éventuels la première
question
deuxième question comment est ce que
vous expliquez que l'isoméride et le
dinh intel été retiré à peu près à la
même époque et la psy j'en ai consommé
beaucoup la lame est la molécule active
du d'udine intel ressemble quand même
étrangement à celle de l'isoméride et à
celle du médiator donc je voudrais
savoir quelle quel processus a fait que
ce dîner elle a été retiré de façon
extrêmement rapide et je dirais
dirigiste alors que les autres
médicaments sont restés sur le marché
plus longtemps oui alors peut-être sauf
si vous ne le souhaitez pas on va
procéder peut-être à l'audition de trois
questions et en plus et ensuite vous
répondrai aux trois questions est ce que
vous êtes d'accord vous préférez qui
répondent question par question
alors monsieur desessard oui mais
écoutez moi je vous ai entendu madame et
je dois dire que je suis un peu perplexe
parce que à chaque fois que vous vous
posez une question le rapporteur
président vous avez dit mais là je
pouvais pas parce qu'il y avait l'europe
ah ben là je pouvais pas parce que mon
directeur il n'avait pas l'air d'accord
voilà je pouvais pas et puis à la fin
vous dites me back six laboratoires
effectivement l'avait retiré vous auriez
été d'accord donc moi je vous à dire je
traduis ça peut-être de façon un peu
courtes et rapides mais en face c'est
l'impression vous m'avez donné donc la
question que vous pose est-ce que vous
concevez comme le rôle de l' agence
comme un rôle de journalistique c'est à
dire vous faites le point une fois de
temps en temps pour vous envoyer
l'information générale ou est ce que
vous faites vous concevez le rôle de l'
agence comme devant sans les problèmes
anticipant les situations et dire que
vous exercer un contrôle sur l'ensemble
des médicaments pour la santé des gens
mais pour le moment j'ai plutôt vu un
service administratif qui et empilait
les dossiers puis qui faisait preuve
d'une certaine inertie que cette
comparaison avec le journalisme soit pas
ressentie par les journalistes comme une
critique alors que ils ont effectué ce
travail leur travail remarquablement
merci de re autant de l'afssaps donc
cette comparaison
mais cette remercie mais c'était pas une
comparaison je dois dire que je
demandais à madame de préciser quelle
était la mission
voilà bon madame le 1er février 2001
servier vous envoie un courrier
décrivant un protocole d'étude sur 12
mois qui inclut un suivi cardiaque
bref des échographies tout cela traîne
en longueur alors d'abord pourquoi
et ce n'est qu'en 2006 que cette étude
de ce fait et elle n'est rendu
finalement qu'en 2009 à l'absence alors
pourquoi n'avoir pas insisté auprès d
abord servier pour lutter pour que ces
données sur le médiator soient
transmises en un an comme c'est
l'habitude et nombre en trois ans à la
question vous pouvez répondre s'il vous
plaît je fais alors il y avait une
première question qui concerne l
la lettre de servier en septembre mais
ça a été plus qu'une led ça a été une
annonce mondial du retrait de
commercialisation d'isoméride et
pondérale qui fait que nous l'avons
appris
quelques heures avant le retrait et nous
avons à l'époque avec le directeur qui
était didier tabuteau fait ce qu'il
fallait pour que le produit soit soit
évidemment suspendu l'utilisation du
produit la prescription la délivrance et
interviennent immédiatement
donc c'est comme cela que je vois mais
c'est le laboratoire servier qui a
retiré l'isoméride et le pondéral ou ce
comme en espagne ou c'est vous qui avait
longtemps j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était dans un esprit d'extrêmes
précautions quoi que le laboratoire
avait consenti
trois jours après que ce retrait est eu
lieu aux états unis de le faire quoi ce
n'est pas ce qui montre bien sa grande
compassion une fois encore l'espace et
je ne sens pas que je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'on présente les choses
écoutez dans les souvenirs puisque gyan
j'étais chef d'unité à new york
ah ça a été une
on ça a été une décision de la part de
servier extrêmement brutale oui c'était
qui est extrait dir écho talent 1 et qui
a été suivie d'une suspension
d'autorisation de mission de marché
immédiate dans les pouilles et suivent
n'est pas le choix mais c'est quand même
servier qui a retiré dans un par
précaution ce produit
d'accord mais ce n'est pas l'âge ans
avec sa mission de pharmacovigilance qui
a permis que le produit soit retirée
nous étions je vous je rappelle quand
même qu'à cette époque nous étions les
conditions de prescription et de
délivrance des anorexigènes avait été
extrêmement resserré et restreintes
depuis depuis plusieurs années connu
c'est oui oui c'est que nous étions pas
2 puis 4 2 puis voilà
depuis j'ai connu comme nous avions nous
et que nous arrivions au bout de la
réévaluation européenne l'europe avait
jugé puisqu'il y avait eu un arbitrage
donc vous savez que l'arbitrage les
décisions sont contraignantes et avait
décidé de laisser le produit sur le
marché mais dans des dans une une niche
qui faisait qu' on était passé de
quelques centaines de milliers de boîtes
mois a même pas quelques milliers à donc
le produit était le premier était
surveillé et je rappelle aussi que bien
évidemment on est vigilant et qu'on
surveille aussi ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays
nous avions connaissance des premiers
cas rapportés par la mayo clinic de
valvulopathie et nous avions
immédiatement fait une réunion et on
c'était pour essayer de voir si en
europe et en particulier en france nous
avions ce problème que nous n'avions
pour les réunions vous êtes imbattable
il y en a eu 17 ans tout le reste ou
vous êtes plus critiquable c'est sur les
actions suivraient c'est sa salle
derrière noteront les réunions n'y a pas
de problème ensuite alors eu question
suivante qui est la deuxième question de
malades
monsieur desessard d'autres questions je
crois sur ledit n'at-elle donc je redis
ce que j'ai dit au début c'est que au
tout début la lorsqu'il ya eu la
problématique qui s'est posé et la
nécessité d'élargir la l'évaluation à
haute aux autres anorexigène que les
fins furent amine puisqu'on a commencé
avec l'isoméride et pondérale et on a
rajouté tous les anorexigènes i contre
le waf lurex nom qui elle aurait une
autorisation de mise sur le marché avec
une indication revendiquer validé validé
revendiez et une autorisation de mise
sur le marché dans l'aide à la perte de
poids ce qui n'était pas le cas de
médiator je vous ai dit que lorsque nous
avons étendu
l'enquète et vous saviez pas que c'est
quand même un anorexigène au sens de la
classification de ms non encore encore
encore encore alors c'est arrivé à votre
conscience à quel beau mot à kehl à
quelle époque
la prise de conscience que ce benfluorex
était inscrit au cou pita pita beaucoup
plus tard en ce qui concerne a des
contacts très étroits avec l' oms
comment quand vous étiez l'europe vous
n'aviez pas des contacts avec l'om est
pour mais bien sûr que si mais ça
n'était pas venu à l'idée de l'influx au
rex
orex anorexie ces années venu à l'idée
d'aucun pharmacologue y compris à
l'étranger de alors ça je m'inscris en
faux des 73 ya des pharmacologues mais
qui n'avait pas effectivement là la
compétence laura que peuvent avoir les
grands pharmacologue meetic qui des 73
un d eux
après dead et 60 puisqu il a été déposé
en 74 des 76 indiquer exactement ce
qu'on a découvert sept ans plus tard
relisez le numéro 4 de la revue
pratiques et qui indique exactement ce
qui nous a fallu vingt ans pour
connaître mais si je ne conteste
absolument pas mais j'essaye de rester
brousseau j'essaie de tout à fait
j'essaye de rester le plus là humble le
pup le voilà je n'ai pas je n'ai pas la
prétention d'avoir des compétences d'un
grand pharmacologue j'avais la
prétention saviano côté comme commandant
la vie à vos côtés mais tous tous ceux à
nos côtés a notamment que ce soit en
interne ou en externe
tous les experts à qui nous avons fait
appel pour nous aider à essayer de 2,2
de résoudre ccse ce dossier je les gens
jouent ils pas le souvenir
personnellement d'avoir entendu d'avoir
entendu quiconque nous reprendre où nous
alerter en me disant attendez vous êtes
en train de laisser sur le chemin un
produit qui se désespèrent la question
de monsieur monsieur on arrive là alors
il faudra le rôle d'anticipation
à cette époque là parce que je voudrais
ne pas ne pas parler maintenant puisque
les jeux je pense quand même que depuis
que je suis arrivé en forme à que j'ai
en ce début des années 70 j'ai quand
même vu le système changeait s'améliorer
et au fil du temps et au fil des crises
1 quand même essayer de prendre en
compte les insuffisances les
dysfonctionnements essayer d'améliorer
le système qui maintenant anticipe
beaucoup plus qu'il anticipait à
l'époque alors je suis beaucoup plus
sont souvent pas depuis 2005 oui ça
c'est clair quand vous dites ça ben si
si si si ce que moi je me suis de toute
façon c'est écrit dans les temples dans
les textes je rappelle qu'au début la
définition de la pharmacovigilance je
rappelle c'était l'ensemble des
activités pour gérer le risque des
médicaments s'était dit à l'europe dans
les conditions normales d'utilisation
normales monsieur décemment réponse
monsieur des essarts s'il vous plaît
madame casto pouvez-vous répondre à
monsieur des essarts nous allons faire
l'impasse sur dix dates elle même si je
crois vous avez commencé de réponse et
répondre c'est bon ça va
question de monsieur des essarts donc
monsieur disait sardi que nous avons
failli
en manquant d'anticipation et et en ne
prenant pas la mesure des données
disponibles de la bleue en gros bon jeu
je peux dire en tout cas en mon âme et
conscience
jusqu en 98 que ce dossier que qu'on
suivait alors vous pouvez dire
effectivement qu'il ya eu des tas de
réunions mais je rappelle quand même que
les centres de pharmaco gens se
réunissent tous les mois
donc c'est pas étonnant qu'ils aient des
réunions et c'est pas étonnant que ces
dossiers que ces problèmes ne bottent
décision c'est problématique soit
inscrit ce sont des groupes
opérationnels techniques qui sont là
pour voir en fonction des données
disponibles et des informations qui sont
recueillies comment avancer dans la dent
dans l'évaluation du dossier et
éventuellement recommander des mesures
s'il le fallait et c'est vrai que
l'ensemble du système de
pharmacovigilance avec les sens de
pharmacovigilance dans le cadre de ces
comités techniques jusqu'à la mi 98 n'a
pas n'a pas considéré n'a pas considéré
qu' il y avait des éléments ou des
arguments suffisants pour prendre une
mesure qui était la mesure de suspension
d'un produit pour lequel il y avait
effectivement une parenté chimique et
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur à à une
reconnaissance par l'om s2 d'un effet de
l'effet anorexigène
il y avait très peu de notification
spontanée très peu de notifications
spontanées qui remontait au système et
c'est là d'ailleurs une des
problématiques
c'est que le système de
pharmacovigilance encore jusqu'à
maintenant un repose beaucoup sur le
recueil d ad sur le recueil sur leur
accueil des notifications spontanées
c'est à dire lorsqu'un professionnel de
santé bientôt un patient une association
de patients puisqu'il rentre dans le
système avec le décret qui est à la
signature du ministre
lorsque le
le professionnel de santé suspecte cas
un événement indésirable pourraient être
associés à la prise d'un médicament
il se doit c'est une obligation de le
déclarer au système de pharmacovigilance
et quand même il ya quelque chose de
très de traits de très contrariant avec
avec ce dossier il d'autres dossiers
d'ailleurs c'est effectivement l'une
grand une grande sous notification avec
finalement inc
quand on est arrivé à cannes en 2009 au
moment de la décision
vous savez bien que y'avait au maximum
une quarantaine même pas de deux cas
rapportés soit d'hypertension épuisé
alors ça
trouvez que c'est passé à ça a été assez
pour que la décision oui je la question
que je me pose non messieurs qui se
développe c'est l'arrêt on décèle une
seule en italie une seule mais en france
il ya 99
vous aviez un mickael enfants des contes
l'italie a fait sa décision pour autres
pour d'autres ismes subtilisé vous avez
raison mais l'espagne c'est clair c'est
quand même moi rapports avec or nous
n'en avait eu dans 99
marseille va pas le temps est de traiter
la façon dont vous l'avez traité 1
mais il ne c'était suffisant pour
supprimer pour suspendre le médiator en
vous n'avez pas fait le monsieur cazaux
je répète ma question pourquoi le la
proposition de servier protocole d'étude
sur le médiateur par échographie amis
d'abord qui était proposé en 2001 n'a
été reprise par l'aps apcom 2005 et
pourquoi on lui a laissé trois ans alors
que c'est habituellement un an pour
transmettre ces données
alors
notre ordre mills est pas posé tout à
l'heure est-ce que ça de votre service
vous avez eu connaissance de situations
de conflits intérêts et comment
celles-ci ont-elles été géré je vais
donc en 2001 à la suite de la de
l'évaluation italienne et française
nous concluons que nous avons besoin
d'une étude qui puisse rapidement
répondre à la question est ce que
d'abord le produit effectivement et
efficace en comparaison avec d'autres
antidiabétiques
et d'autre part nous souhaitions avoir
cette évaluation échocardiographique des
patients avant traitement et à la fin du
traitement
bon nous avons eu un premier protocole
au cours de l'année 2001 qui a été
évidemment regarder de près doc et par
les italiens et par les français je
rappelle que nous c'était une demande
européenne
les italiens en fête ont répondu plus
vite que nous au laboratoire en faisant
un certain nombre de remarques et donc
de toute façon le premier pays qui a
réagi le laboratoire devait suivre
alors si j'ai bien compris les choses
parce que c'est une séquence qui qui qui
met que j'ai eu un peu de mal à
comprendre
ensuite c'est que le laboratoire aurait
dit que la faisabilité d'une étude à la
fois d'efficacité en prenant d'ailleurs
un comparateur qui était pas le bon
et de deux
de tolérance l'étude de faisabilité
avait montré que ce n'était pas possible
et ils ont à l'époque fait en deux fois
en deux temps l'étude moulin d'abord don
qui est une étude d'efficacité et qui a
été disponible en 2005 puis l'étude
regulate qui a été conduite 2005 2006
2007 et pour lequel nous avons eu les
résultats à notre demande
parce que quand nous avons eu les
résultats à la commission nationale de
septembre 2009 c'était des résultats
préliminaires
nous n'avions pas les résultats écrit ça
a été une présentation du du laboratoire
micro on vous entend pas sur tous les
jeudis un peu comme je dis il faut un
énorme pour ce teint ce type de produits
et là on laisse trois ans pour avoir le
résultat comme le protocole d'italie
le protocole d'une telle étude pour en
avoir un peu l'habitude demande quand
même un certain la rédaction du
protocole va assez vite
lala ensuite trouver tous les centres
qui vont participer l'inclusion des
patients l'obtention de la cnil c'est
quand même ça prend quand même plus d'un
an
quelquefois ensuite il a fallu faire
l'étude et ensuite évidemment pouvoir
analyser les résultats
donc si vous voulez je je ne suis pas
particulièrement étonnée mais bon au vu
de ce que ce que je vois avec d'autres
études que nous demandons que ça ait
pris un total de 3 a eu trois ans dans
deux pour pour la construire
la sphère et analyser les résultats
madame caméraman vous avez la parole
c'est le président c'était juste une
question pratique puisqu'on on débute
nos travaux est ce que les intervenants
commençant leur intervention pourrait
nous donner les définitions par exemple
ses traditions oui parce que nous ne
sommes pas tous médecins ou pharmaciens
et il serait utile que nous ayons les
définitions à merci on me dit que le
secrétariat thatta nous préparer à
l'excès parce que c'est avec les
acronymes et enfin ce que ce que
signifient ces acronymes fait une amie
si je comprends plus question à laquelle
je me suis permis de répondre
puisqu'elle ne s'adressait pas à vous
madame casto pour une fois monsieur le
maine ce prix là madame vous nous avez
dit le système de pharmacovigilance
enfin quand fonctionne sur la base et ça
c'est le mode recueil spontanée les
informations qui sont ensuite transmises
au comité technique qui sont rapprochés
bien évidemment au centre de
pharmacovigilance
est-ce que c'est toujours ainsi ou est
ce que il n'y a pas d évaluation
systématique des nouvelles molécules qui
sortent par exemple et une fois que
ceux-ci
cette molécule est pris en considération
que la nocivité et est perçue comment se
fait la suite de la décision dont je
veux bien admettre qu'elles durent un
certain temps
et là vous illustrez s'il vous plaît
comment ça s'est passé pour le médiateur
deuxième question vous nous avez dit en
europe c'est extrêmement compliqué de se
faire entendre si on est minoritaire
c'est compliqué sur quoi pour se faire
entendre sur quoi si on est minoritaire
parce que si c'est pratiquement en
europe si on est minoritaire différents
temps je veux dire qu'il ya là un déni
par rapport à l'aspect scientifique est
ce que l'on soit minoritaire ou
majoritaire
si on peut démontrer la nocivité d'un
médicament en l'occurrence ou d'une
molécule c'est pas d'être minoritaire ou
majoritaire parce que là c'est des
rapports de force de pouvoir qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la science
ils n'ont pas valeur heuristique est-ce
qu'on va profiter de la question de
revenir à sous et ensuite vous aurez la
parole mais la question elle est
relativement sain parce que tout ce
qu'on développe et madame y compris en
ce qui concerne les incertitudes
inhérentes à la mise sur le marché d'un
médicament
ces gens remarquables mais au sens
péjoratif du terme
et quand vous dites surveiller
surveiller il ya des des produits qui
sont mis sur le marché qui selon être
médicaments qui sont assujettis à ce
qu'on appelle le principe de précaution
mais là où ça devient beaucoup plus
grave c'est que avant le médiator
effectivement il ya des zones arides
avec une molécule qui était quasiment
semblables donc cette zone d'incertitude
ou d'un dispositif que vous qualifiez
des certains qui à moi perso ça me
choque est doublement coupable là parce
qu'encore une fois l'isoméride sa
prescription a pu être un signal armes
très très fort et dans les
interrogations liées à l'utilisation de
l'isoméride aurait dû générer presque
mécaniquement une interdiction est en
tout cas un retard considérable au
niveau de la mise sur le marché du
médiator
je m'explique pas pourquoi
je pense qu'elle est comprise et jusqu'à
jusqu'à date quand même jusqu'à quelle
date c'était pas un anorexigène
écoutez je pense que n'a pas été
considéré comme un anorexigène manager
louis jusqu'à ans de manière certaine
jusqu à l ami 95 au moment où
effectivement se pose la question et on
se dit attention ce produit pourrait
peut-être être aurais je pense que
j'aurai xi gène médicament pas celui qui
est dans les préparations magistrales
plus tard will ans plus tard à 98,98
tout a commencé à chanter que c'était un
anorexigène a vraiment oui d'accord
est-ce que ça correspond à ce courrier
qui a été adressée le 11 septembre 98
par les trois courts médecins conseils
nationaux des principales caisses
d'assurance maladie au directeur de
l'agencé sujet du mésusage du médiator
non c'était avant puisque les comités
techniques qui avait formalisé renforcer
l' enquête de pharmacovigilance était
était au mois d'avril
et c'est 1982 connaissance comment cette
lettre vous avez eu connaissance
oui qu'est-ce que vous avez faire et
nous avons répondu nous avons répondu en
disant que nous avions cette enquête de
pharmacovigilance qui était en cours
parce qu'effectivement nous avions des
doutes et par ailleurs il ya une autre
direction qui a répondu sur les données
d'exposition tous répondu vous avez pas
pris après là là là vous avez répondu
n'a remis ce qui est déjà beaucoup
géante jeu je réponds en tant que chef
d'unité de fermer l'usiné je serais
sûrement bien assisté s'interrogeront
sur supérieur hiérarchique bien normal
bien sûr bien sûr mais commence par
étant donné que les premiers cas index
qui qui qui commence à inquiéter comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure et le
premier cas de valvulopathies enfin
d'insuffisance aortique lé 19 de 99 et
le premier cas d'hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire d'y purger un patient
de jeu à 99 et à l'époque mais ça suffit
toujours pas deux de mon côté de mon
côté d'accord de mon côté je fais aussi
jolies fesses une lettre pour expliquer
que ces deux cas plus là les données
pharmacologiques plus et que nous avons
sur le produit nous font dire que healy
a certainement à à à accélérer le
processus de réévaluation
donc cette conclusion 2009 c'est la
conclusion de l'unité de
pharmacovigilance fin juin 2008
d'accord 98 excusez moi j'ai arrêté de
lutz était semblable
oui mais vous avez la passion qu'on a
perdu notre tante en 14-18 et 2008 alten
6 et 13 passes à 98 bien vu alors oui
monsieur le maire et monsieur mirassou
aller alors monsieur le mail c'est là la
difficulté de l'intrication entre les
deux systèmes les systèmes d'évaluation
européennes et nationales
pour tout vous dire de l'expérience que
j'en ai depuis les années soixante
treize au moment où j'ai commencé à
faire de la pharmacovigilance et
jusqu'en 95
les choses étaient assez simple dans la
mesure où de toute façon c'était une
responsabilité nationale non seulement
de dents de surveiller évidemment le
profil de risque et de prendre les
décisions qu'ils sont qui s'imposait
d'ailleurs à ce titre je voudrais
rappeler que dès que le isoméride a été
mis sur le marché
nous avons mis une enquête de
pharmacovigilance parce que nous
connaissions pondérale qui avait eu un
premier cas d'hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire qui avait été rapporté
quelques années avant et que donc on
suspects est effectivement qu'ils
méritent se comporte comme pondérale les
deux avaient évidemment une plaine une
autorisation de mise sur le marché
planer entière comme anorexigène bien
à partir de 95 nous arrivons dans
l'europe du médicament avec une agence
européenne qui s'intéresse tout d'abord
c'est vrai à toutes les procédures
centralisée donc nous sommes d'accord
pour lé procédure centralisée
la commission qui décide là l'europe
joue son jeu et de toute façon tous les
dossiers qui sont vu puisque c'est
l'europe qui en a la responsabilité sont
là les décisions sont contraignantes et
sont prises à la majorité
donc je rappelle que nous sommes
maintenant 27 ce qui devient plus
complexe
très rapidement nous avons eu un certain
nombre de problématiques que nous france
nous avons firme remonter à l'europe dès
le début des années quatre-vingt quinze
il n'y a pas eu que les anorexigènes
il y en a eu d'autres d'autres
médicaments pour lesquels nous avons
estimé que comme le produit se trouvait
sur d'autres marchés
c'était notre responsabilité que les
autres pays soient informés et deux
participent effectivement à l'évaluation
lorsque c'est une procédure formelle dit
d'arbitrage ça revient à dire que de
toute façon c'est le comité des
spécialités pharmaceutiques qui procède
à l'évaluation elle qui va émettre des
recommandations et qui devront être
entérinées ou pape arbres par la
commission bruxelles et donc
contraignantes
toute la difficulté est lorsqu'il ne
s'agit pas effectivement d'une procédure
formalisée d'arbitrage c'est à dire
lorsque au niveau du d'un des groupes de
travail du bus du comité des spécialités
pharmaceutiques et le groupe de
pharmacovigilance
il y à un tour de table des états
membres qui chacun présente ces
problématiques et lorsqu une
problématique peut être partagée par
d'autres pays parce que le produit et
sur plusieurs marchés
la la la l'évaluation peut se faire en
commun il peut y avoir des
recommandations mais qui sont la plupart
du temps comme ça n'a pas ce côté formel
pas toujours suivie et chacun repart et
fait ce qu'il veut et la difficulté
comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est de
pouvoir que tous les pays participent
vraiment à cette évaluation
quand une grande partie non pas le
produit sur le marché
uno ou considèrent qu'ils n'ont pas les
mêmes les mêmes préoccupations
je peux prendre l'exemple de ketum du
chi que nous avons suspendu pour lequel
bon il a fallu leur met sur le marché le
marché comme vous le savez à la suite
d'une décision du conseil d'état est que
après un recours du laboratoire ce qui
n'est pas le cas non du médiator alors
je j'arrivais le médiator vous aviez la
possibilité de le retirer sans être
obligé de passer par les structures
européennes
oui pourquoi ne l'avez-vous ne l'avons
pas fait ce que je veux je vous ai je
vous ai dit la stricte vérité c'est que
au tout début dans les premières années
il n'a pas compte et est considéré comme
un anorexigène et faisant partie de la
liste européenne est dit qu'en 98 avant
je relate que j'essaye de faire l'époque
94 98 et ensuite à partir de 98 ou à la
suite de la suspension d'isoméride on
considère que là il faut vraiment faire
cette enquête de pharmacovigilance et
essayer de 2 2 2 comment dire de pousser
la la la la la veille et la surveillance
du produit pour effectivement mettre en
évidence le plus rapidement possible le
profil de risque qui pour le moment été
et est potentiellement effectivement
similaire à isoméride et et pondérale il
a fallu attendre le premier cas les
premiers cas de valvulopathies dans
l'est en début 99 et le premier cas
d'hypertension artérielle pulmonaire qui
a été rapporté en juin 98 pour
effectivement considérer que
il y avait matière à revoir à refaire
une réévaluation du bénéfice risque est
là le problème est le suivant
et ça je le dis tout à fait c'est que un
produit lorsqu on le surveille
à un moment donné la la la l'évaluation
du risque ne peut se faire strictement
qu'en prenant en compte les données
d'efficacité et le bénéfice et les
conditions d'utilisation du produit
ce qu'eta mais je les dis ceux qui
savent mais ça plaide pas en faveur du
médiator ce que vous dites à ce que
mediapart ou si on connaît que série qui
servait à rien monsieur j'essaye
d'expliquer comment le ressenti que j'ai
du dossier et je je je je pense qu'il ya
eu un problème de ja imprègne de process
un moment donné où j'ai le sentiment que
l'on voyait le risque parce que le
risque a été vraiment a été vraiment
suivi sans s'en prendre en compte
peut-être tous les aspects du bénéfice
et al'inverse une efficacité et une
évaluation d'efficacité qui ne prenait
peut-être pas suffisamment en compte les
données de risques alors que la la cette
notion de rêve de bénéfice risque elle
est devenue évidemment essentiel avec
les textes européens et de de 2004 et
encore plus maintenant avec la révision
communautaire qui a introduit le fait
que la réévaluation du risque ne peut
pas se faire sans la prise en compte de
l' usage thérapeutique et donc des
bénéfices du produit j'ai eu trop
l'impression enfin cesser le le
sentiment que j'ai quand je regarde le
dossier
on est obligé de se quitter et toute la
partie institutionnelle mais ce que nous
avions eu cette situation au moment de
la sphère du vioxx puisque le sénat a
déjà élaboré un rapport notamment
pour remettre en place une nouvelle
évaluation et tout un contrôle du
médicament
ce rapport nous l'avant avec vettier
partie de la mission l'avons été
rapporteur anne marie payet et moi même
et nous avions proposé un certain nombre
de solutions dont on peut s'étonner
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne soit pas lui en
tout cas que le rapport de l'igas
rejoignent nos conclusions
mais dans les auditions nous avions eu à
l'époque il y avait quelque chose qui
m'avait interpellé et ça m'a interpellé
quand on te dit tout à l'heure il y
avait 40 notification nous avait été dit
que finalement un médicament aujourd'hui
été mis sur le marché
selon un modèle pasteurien alors que
donc pour les pathologies conçoit type
antibiotiques
or la plupart des médicaments
aujourd'hui sont dispensés pour des
pathologies à long terme et donc le fait
de le mettre sur le masi et le marché
avec un modèle qui est un modèle
pasteurien fait qu'à un moment quand on
le prend à long terme
il y à une évaluation du bénéfice risque
qui dysfonctionne par rapport au modèle
qui a été mis sur le marché et donc c
est ce que finalement quelque part la
notion de bénéfice risque n'est pas dû à
la mauvaise fort à la mauvaise
formalisation du modèle qui ne
correspond plus aujourd'hui aux
pathologies en courge parce que bon
c'est fait de quelques fois vous hésité
quand vous avez une deux trois quatre
quarante notification et que le citoyen
ne comprend pas les standards de mise
sur le marché d'autorisation de mise sur
le marché depuis que je suis dans le
médicament ont bien évolué et
heureusement et les et vous comme vous
le savez à la suite effectivement d'une
de ses miss de cette mission et en
particulier de la révision
d des textes législatifs pour essayer de
renforcer la surveillance de des risques
et du bénéfice risque des médicaments
il ya quand même eu des outils qui ont
été mis en place à partir de juillet
décembre 2005
et c'est à dire que lorsqu'on met un
médicament sur le marché
d'accord alors on part du principe que
rien n'est fixé
rien n'est figé et que tout est à faire
et tout et à tout et à apprendre aux
plans de 2,2 de la deûle à des risques
dans la mesure où on sait très bien que
les conditions assez aseptisé des essais
cliniques ne permettent absolument pas
de pouvoir prévoir réellement comment le
médicament va se comporter va se
comporter une fois mis sur le marché et
c'est la raison pour laquelle les plans
de gestion de risques on a mis en place
à l'europe mais même aux états unis et
en france c'est justement toutes les
mesures qu'on peut met pour accompagner
la surveillance d'un produit qu'on met
sur le marché et c'est pas uniquement
les notifications spontanées
c'est pas uniquement des études pour
confirmer des risques qu'on suspecte ou
pour quantifier ou pour expliquer en
trouvant des facteurs de risque c'est
aussi des études d'utilisation ça c'est
extrêmement important des études
d'utilisation qui nous permettent de
dire très vite comment le produit est
prescrit comment il est délivré comment
il est utilisé et de pouvoir si c'est
nécessaire
voilà ça c'est la théorie bon écoute
depuis monsieur oui oui oui oui bah je
n'essaye de ces la tuerie oui mais là
depuis qu'une pratique c'est pas tout à
fait les choses dans fin on va être
obligé mes chers collègues et je m'en
excuse d'interrompre ici cette audition
quitte à la reprendre ultérieurement si
nous l'estimons nécessaire
je je pense que malgré le temps restera
qui nous était imparti nous avons pu
poser les questions que nous souhaitions
et n'ont donc remercier madame casto de
cette livrée à ce jeu des questions et
j'aurais moi-même eu à lui poser est
dans la question mais malheureusement ce
ne sera pas le cas donc il est possible
qu'on la fasse revenir et et on penser
oui il enverra une liste aussi par écrit
même sur l'aspect ça tu lis par écrit et
puis si les réponses que vous nous
apportez suscite d'autres questions on
envisagera éventuellement de vous
auditionné une seconde fois surtout
lorsque nous aurons auditionner d'autres
membres de l' agence fin 2 de l'afssaps
donc en vous remerciant je vais donc
levé la séance et puis 0 passé à la
personne suivante merci madame
voilà pour cette première audition de la
mission d'information du sénat sur le
scandale du médiator à suivre le journal
de 19h présenté ce soir par michel
grossiord merci de votre fidélité et à
très bientôt sur notre antenne